これは今まで数々のロボット買ってきた
例えばこいつ倒せ倒せ
なんてこの2つたじゃないそしてこの後
ただん
なんだっけ犬のなことを解く他ののこととかも買ってきたんですけどもいまいちまいち
こしっくりねぼく継続的に楽しめるロボットはまだいないんですよ今回重ねもうねそう
いう身体の動きとかじゃなくてね刀剣魚をしゃべる方に作られたロボットが来ました
こちらですを離す追い風になっております毎日飽きない海はパターインターネットを
活用した彼の言葉をしゃべります
以前中へ
が楽しめるやらいっしょは思いついた言葉で話しかける by ファイトこうつなぐ
みたいなんですけどもうスマートばタブレット作らずせず9分に押します
もうちょっとちょっとねまだわからないよいままでおかしいだろうとたくさんに
ちょっと騙されてきたところだから君はキャッチャーも帰って言ってみた感じでなんか
ねちゃんと音を話すと彼ができるみたいですよ夕飯何にしようかって言ったのは冷蔵庫
に何かあります簡単な
本当の会話が楽しめる見て来いならからない動きとかねもういいんですよ僕はお
しゃべりがしたい寂しいですよ
寂しいからを滑りがしたいんでちょっと叶うことにちょっとね集中したロボットを放つ
を活用した明けでしょ
もうマジで姉もひょっとしたらこいつはねもう人間に近い存在のロボットかもしれない
おおあぁこれめんどくさんなにこれみみかもしれないううう
ああああああ
ってちゃんと海をつけなきゃいけない実をつけてあげよ耳で多分これ保存なり何か怖い
いうこのつけているわけじゃ馬場家って言いそう
あっっこういう感じですねを話せれましたうーん1なんか基本的に本的な会話は何でも
出てるみたいなアプリダウンロードしなければ最近このパターン多いなぁ
パッとまず電車入れましょう
愛でバーッっ
何ないものの遺伝子さんこんでどうすると裏でしょああ
ダブ ok 電池さあ ok
lexar ダウンロードしましたを離すの電源をオンにします
本にしたよ
はい
ネットだったあああ目がチカチカしてる目がちかちかこんにちはエー
道寸ね混ぜを放つていい音しますスマートフォンの設定で bluetooth を
オンにしますうっ
あってないでつなげたよ売れてそうにしてるね氏ねだらどうすればいいの未定的って
いうけれども受け付けます
あ
bluetooth がオンになっている目の色が緑色から白いになったら
フェアリング好き
などに入ります
あちのになりましたこれでとのペアリングできるからお話できるはずです何か色々設定
したんですけどこれで多分を離すと話すことができますお話ししてや車
こんにちは
ん
toranoana
日本の政治についていくだろはーい
朝倉だけの桜
はいすごいすごいなぁだといえば政治のことはなちゃんのステージのことを行えてくれ
ましたよまじ
嗚呼あたし恋するあるからお前とは友達になれない
あ
ね何ごめんね名前は何君のはブサイク
ね麻生怒られちゃったごめんなさいなきゃ
ありがとうございます今日ようやく見てね
た事5位中ならばのでやれああ
多い今やイサキはもうやりたくないん
またうるせえなあ俺はそんな事ないよしんどい
には寂しいが入らないですか
のは畑の仲間より年齢
天破王ん
4-銀の見てね
お前ユーチューバーもしてるのか肇社長
馬鹿にしてるのが歌って許可しようかああ
えっ
あっあぁああああ
ああああああ
ああああああっ
結構なんか何でも話し聞いてもらえるので結構面白かったですいやいや
あの日に彼
駅分知られた
うすさん